a day in my life as a bakery owner it's
5am and I'm ready to start the day it's
a Saturday which is the busiest day in
the bakery so the first thing I'm going
to do is bake off a ton of cookies while
those are baking I'm getting ready to
pipe some lemon curd into these
pre-prepared Tarts and then I'm going to
make a quick meringue that I will pipe
on top and blow torch
[Music]
almost time to open the door so I put
everything in the pastry case here she
is ready before opening about five
minutes before I open the door and get
ready to serve some customers for the
day sometimes you have a line of people
waiting out front sometimes it takes
five or ten minutes for people to get
out of bed in the morning so I'm folding
some boxes in the bakery we all like to
share tasks this is a few hours later
because it got so busy
and because our best-selling flavor is
always the first to sell out I'm making
a batch of that it's the NYC cookie
which I named after my favorite cookie
in the world from the Von Bakery in New
York City